all happening today career Pathways for
trade jobs in the air conditioning and
HVAC field both very important to Las
Vegas family as the heat arrives oh yeah
U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics says it
is a growing field and our Laura
negretti is at the College of Southern
Nevada's campus near Western High School
and HVAC job fair happening later today
Lauren good morning how's it going
good morning you guys yes it's happening
at three to five pm today here at the
apply Technologies campus like you said
Bonanza and Decatur I am here with one
of the instructors Tom Newkirk to talk
more about yes why this is such an
important infrastructure backbone of Las
Vegas well without air conditioning
without Refrigeration we wouldn't have a
city it
the backbone we have to keep food cold
we have to keep our guests cool
basically it's an industry that keeps
the city afloat definitely now the
Giants for community members come on
down bring your
room here at CSN it's very Hands-On this
right here explain uh this kind of a
refrigerator right here next to us well
this is part of the commercial program
this is actually a miniaturized of one
of these walk-in refrigerators or
freezers and this is their final they
have to wire up the entire
trainer they have to pipe it up
install a filter dryer and
moisture indicator
pulley vacuum on the system
charge it and make it run this is
basically their final
it's basically like hooking up one of
these walk-ins
yeah all important job kind of aspects
here here in Las Vegas well don't go
anywhere because coming up in the next
half hour we're going to be inside the
job fair space talking to a student who
now has a wonderful career here in Las
Vegas in HVAC back to you guys